hello now welcome to the GameSpot
theater everybody making games is a huge
complex process and something that
scales exponentially once the bigger
your game gets and we think of immersive
sim games like System Shock and thief
and Deus Ex which all have rich
interactive worlds with deep and
interlocking systems the thought of all
the work that goes into their creation
is just like headache-inducing but today
we're lucky enough to have with us a
developer who's had an incredibly
integral part to the creation of a
couple of these games we have sebastian
Matan from arcane student in france who
was the art director on dishonored and
now dishonored do a round of applause is
a bastard I'm also joined by my friend
Daniel Hines from sneaky bastard hey
everyone who I'd say is a pretty big
designer fan and you say that I'm small
yeah I really enjoy this game I've
played it over and over again we we
produced a 100 page magazine about the
original game where I was like enough to
interview key people from arcane people
who worked on the deals he and people
who are inspired by the game in the
community people who speedrun the game
people who play it using trick tactics
and all this really cool stuff so I'm
really looking forward to this yeah and
I think it's fair to say that a lot of
you are just one fan so people like this
game will be coming into play a bit more
later and we will be taking audience
questions I'm at the end of the panel so
please do think of them but first I
thought we'd let Sebastian just take the
reins and kind of give us an in-depth
insight to his work its method and and
the art of dishonored - I'm Sebastian I
thought we might just start about about
you personally like about where you are
we got to where you are today and just
your whole deal all right
I have a good game
well so I've started attacking 12 years
ago well my first job was on very early
- on Dreamcast it was in 99 and that was
my first job in the video game industry
but I was not quite satisfied about how
they managed the art again play the code
so I decided to go back to the
communication industry working on the
Dreamcast no it was super cool this
console was amazing in some of graphics
and what you were able to do at this
time so it was quite surprising compared
to the ps1 at that time and then I
action again I've knocked at the door
Raphael continued open the door and it
was a guy who focused a lot of an
immersive game and they were preparing
darkness area which was expertise - at
the moment and I was really impressed by
how they managed the first-person combat
this was the first time I go to squat in
my hand and fighting guys kicking guys
in a great fantasy war so I said ok
let's let's what together and he allowed
me to a slowly after us to explain
myself and that's quite important as an
artist to convey emotions convey good
quality of concept research etc so
that's what I did during this 12 years
and we have so I've worked on darkness I
am then the economy the industry was
like this so we had some issue we did
our own games called the crossing which
was a parallel world it was a cross
player game it was really interesting
but it was too hard to find a good deal
because people who are afraid about
cross playing etc so we then did some
contract with valve so I did a 5-3 No
no we did an episode it wasn't not quite
an EP that it was a full game raven home
right yeah returned to Lebanon we've
worked on Bioshock 2 into camera in San
Francisco that was my shot yeah yeah to
me yes when you look at the industry now
do you think the crossing would be
easier to sell I think so yeah
it was cross playing you know you play
you play your story and sometimes some
AI are replaced by cheaper game so it's
it's surprising plus it was cross paid
from PC console Allah it wasn't working
we had the two studio already Osteen on
you and we were paying to allowing this
so yes and then I've worked on the
Steven Spielberg Le minou project lMNO
it's the code name and during one year
I've started to do my own photo
reference I went on site you know in
u.s. it was super super nice experience
to do that and then Bethesda they
detected us they were really pleased by
the approach of doing immersive games
great work cool gameplay a strong level
design which is very important to us
so they've detected this DNA and they
wanted to work on a project with us and
then they acquire us so now we are part
of this family with it take the guy who
do work French time tango with Shinji a
bit within and far out etc so that's
cool you're from a fine art background
is that correct yes games
you'll see later but my philosophy is
that you can do art for everything and
the way I think Art Attack n is that it
could be for movie comics
games then later you add up to the core
pillars of a game so you can produce
cool concept art you can do your
reference yourself it says right it can
go for different media I think without
further ado let's go into the art
just wanted to in the behind-the-scenes
look at this game we're all very excited
about okay it's because my notes are
here oops sorry I have a phone call
yes ruff yeah ruff is do but so [ __ ]
yeah no I cannot talk right now I'm
doing a panel at PAX yes tell them that
okay yeah it would be cool to open a
studio in Australia yes I'm for it okay
see you later bye bye yeah thanks
well yeah so I'm already excited to be
with you faith in you I did a long trip
to come here it's 25 hours of flight but
it's really cool to be close to the
audience to the fans to the players so
I'm glad to be here
I like your country roots like whole
Kenya are all series so we'll start with
I will bring you to the behind the
scenes of the project so you'll see some
footage from the in-game but you'll see
a lot of artwork concept art etc and I
forgot my clicker okay cool okay let's
start so what is it didn't look too
visually speaking so you see three
shutters the first is the spirit to me
it's really important to have a spirit
on top of your art this is a philosophy
and the result of all of this is the
style of the game people wonder how we
achieve this style in the game amusia at
the end of the presentation so it all
starts with the recruitment ad with a la
ocean air even a drink a lot of coffee
like drop and I try to I are the best
talents in the world regardless where
they are and where they're from that way
my team is made of strong strong
specialists here you'll see awesome
example from a few artists which is just
the tip of the iceberg by the way we
have a we are 70 artists at the peak of
the production so it starts in Russia
this guy who did that it's not in the
game it's his own project is called
sergey kulikov and to me is one of the
best illustrator i've met in years look
at discover we did for game informer we
don't tend to simply produce visual for
games
that's what I said earlier we create art
so applying what we learned in our
respective fine art school composition
curraghs perspective and also we try to
convey message each time we do an
illustration is it's not just a piece of
art that shows a building or correct
only it's an illustration to mitigate
the killer asteroids orbit is also
really good at portrait is really
talented on different topics so I try to
give him a lot of work to achieve during
the production no problem this is a
Jablonski I click do there so his Tomcat
brother project because to me a header
can occur in 9 and when I saw this I was
like yeah there's something to do with
this gang so it's the same project but a
funded an animation on top of
illustration so what I like with these
artists it's that there are bit crazy
like me with a strong personal identity
and this is key for the success of your
art so look how well he's a stag fitting
of this district so now this is our or
art that you can see and what I like is
the wedding translates my brief into a
piece of visual narration it's not only
as I said just buildings or tractors so
here you can see the god some civilians
that flew that takes the world who who
tagged the world
and sometimes it has a high romantic not
like this it's just a dead body in a
trash bin but it's cool for people that
I came to see what will come next
this is the first piece of the game by
the way it's before we are we put our
hands into the engine cleanse culture
now that's quite a new process in the
industry so my idea is that I wanted to
give a try to this finite approach this
is close to what I've learnt at school
by the way here's the master at work
listening she's a French filter and this
technique allows me to secure the look
Diana to me the style how the lights
reaction on the clay and this is after
the 2d concept the portraits and this is
before 3d modelers start working in the
software's and that way I can unify the
lineup so here it's just one piece but
when you have like ten of them
then we take picture of them we send the
photo to the different artists in the
world in New York in Romania and we have
the artists in France the core team is
in France its unified so they don't go
into different direction in terms of
time we also had the chance to get our
paintings and scripture displayed in
from Museum in Paris during six months
so that's quite cool because when you do
up for games in general it's it's on the
web here it was like six months
displayed on a museum at our uijik in
France in Paris and here we can see the
class class culture on the Left versus
the digital 3d modeling on the right so
as I play to win
also excellent references are key to
succeed in the first page of Google
image is not allowed in my open space
that means that we gather a lot of cool
reference from our master painters that
we put on our data center or we also
have a chef that our line with the
unique books and that way we can analyze
costume gestures
and that to me ethnicity how do like to
react if you look at their hands there's
a lot of story on this table because
they are all from different origin and
that's what we'll do after that in game
we onerous also the life of the citizens
the Anthropology because to me this is
the people from Kanaka could beat this
city this is not us so we try to think
through the minor of the civilians and
other examples the one on the left it's
laying de cura I really loved this tile
and it's really minimalist this this
painting by the way it's really small
and it conveys a lot of information
about how fabrics will react the weight
of the cloth Deanna to me how you deform
and Anatomy so that's quite interesting
and it gives this certain flavor to his
illustration and that's what we will
achieve later in the game work so it's
from different purpley straight or like
this that we take inspiration from we
have also did dedicated website on top
left top right this is shoppi shop he is
a website that so lots of gigantic
photography from the past era
so here it's London 18 something I guess
and it shows London before the bombing
so again you see what you cannot
photograph here now adays and top at the
bottom part is cultural we analyse
culture because it's a static object and
when it's well done it conveys a lot of
emotion so if if it's in a static mode
it works that's a lot of information
that we can get to do our own scripture
in the game then animate it and do some
voice etc so seeking inspiration from
our masters is key to us here it's
rapping and already loved the
we're a build stories through a crowd to
people this is really minimalist in some
of environments but there's a lot of
story everywhere in this painting and so
this is where inspiration and this is
the first illustration we did for the
game and we try not to reproduce the
inspiration it's just we we analyze and
then with digests we train our eyes and
after that we work with the tannins
attack em and they produce this kind of
piece so here you can see the Duke you
can see the early version of Karen gin -
on his left so it's the design has
changed but the information were quite
there you see this this guy underground
who has been bitten up by a god it gives
you information on the era and on the
same vein I repeat from the general one
that it's very important to go inside to
select location and to go there to take
photography yourself you don't only
bring back photography you you bring
back notes smells ideas you talk to
people it's really important and then
you share this with your team so here it
was a shooting in Rome beachings
thoughts Los Angeles I was really
impressed by the writing and it's not
only the writing it's the way it's the
death of the city the rhythm of the
streets the specularity
there's a lot of information in each
foot to you you take here at different
places you have Malibu on the left and
more importance Barcelona on the right
my wish was to go to Havana Cuba but I
was not able to do the trip so I decided
to go to Spain in Barcelona because the
two cities are closing some of
architecture and urbanism it's just that
the level of decay the level of the
history is different and here again
Barcelona and when I take pictures
sometimes it's not just for art
reference it could be Polat for level
design
what we do at a Ken is that when we want
to reach rooftop we don't just put two
or three credits here we try to use the
environments you know it's not gameplay
you know elements that we throw into the
games so here I can imagine I go how do
you call this the white thing yeah
they're owning and then you can
eventually reach balconey and go to the
rooftop and as we have a new power mode
you should be able to do it with no
power so you cannot bring to the roof
directly you have to so each playthrough
can be done you know in different ways
it's a nightmare in terms of level
design and up to justify everything but
in the end the player feels that it's
the freedom he has is very big important
and we've also studied all colonies so
the idea for Kanaka was imagined I would
argue the first time imagine dunwall but
on a southern country and we decided to
go at the edge of the world so it was
important to analyze colony clone is
like this because this is the best way
to understand how people from England
adapt themselves to a warmer area and
here's the reserve this is the final
slide of this part good reference notes
and description it ends up with this mud
ball and of the bay of Kanaka and here
you can feel that it's not the location
where you want to go for your early days
it's still miss Charles it's not Kong
Island but it's a mix of Metropole and
been dead inside you know jack gigantic
forest we will select around the
satellite view okay so the spirit
it's also my team it's a bunch of moose
- so it was November
as I said we were 70 artists working in
outside the studio at the peak and to me
it's essential to sit in matching in the
open space when I say something they all
hear what I say and we get all the
feedbacks at the same times and everyone
is like growing up in terms of quality
and ton of art and I'm really interested
in each individual's this is the only
way to get the best out of them because
when we start a project we know that
we'll work on it for four years three
four years so it's it includes crunch it
includes pressure it includes excitement
so it's very important to be like
energized by your own team and they get
also your energy as the leader of the
art we spend a lot of time training two
different techniques which characterized
as I said with cutting-edge visuals or
the book we open them and we talk about
like fashion or vehicle design and one
other key element of this journal are
the brief and the high level of my
expectation as soon in the past some in
some on some project that the brief were
already minimalist and it's it led to a
wrong you know design then you have to
cut a non redo so that's really
important that you focus a lot on
debrief and here you can see the
importance on the of the brief regarding
I mean it's just the armor family it's
not like something really cool it just
the arm but you can see the silhouettes
of the curve you can see how our button
can impact the plane of the arm you can
feel the weight of the clothes and if
it's well done here then in 3d you know
you'll have a good level for starting
your 3d model being a first-person game
do you think the arms are actually super
important because that's kind of what
you see as the player and that's kind of
what's communicating character yeah plus
we have the doppelganger so we can see
me
when you launch the power we know of
body awareness which is it's a semi body
one as you cannot see your feet like
this but when she moves you see the legs
and it feels more more immersive
you can actually see Emily's colour when
you turn when you're in the car ride
going up we saw like it's like the big
color yeah yeah is it tough with a team
so big 70 artists to kind of negotiate
all the different styles and signature
they sort of wanted to have a signature
look no no it's not that on because they
when they get in the street and we
briefed them we talk to them we I
remember in the past we've got some two
trainings that were at school and we've
detected that they was super they were
trying to do environment but I've
detected that there was super good at
vehicle design industrial design and we
we signed a deal while they were at
school to be sure they will come to the
studio and now they are leading some
work two years after they are contract
so that means it's good yeah and this is
the same with the accuracy of the
feedback so good brief but good
feedbacks also because you iterate
sometimes you get feedback from RV from
the notch of design from the gameplay
you know it's you walk in the middle of
the world team every teams so it's
important that it works so accuracy if
the feedback is key and when I spot
something wrong they say oh you got me
go I know they have to do it again but
it never it doesn't happen so often so
because now they are really good at you
know they know that I'm perfectionist so
yeah talking about the team sometimes
it's really hard so that's why you see
this picture they suffer sometimes due
to the quality our target but under the
sea the result of the award they really
like it and we all like it it's
important to share that the way we work
together because sometimes you know we
have our times
we have to modify stuff we have to add
up to the gameplay or we change the
labor so they don't get you know
everything and you have to explain them
so they suffer but in the end they are
happy so here it's a mash-up of
Kubrick's Clockwork Orange and singing
in the rain so that was up in the studio
what does the same perfectionism meets
lightness so while I already explained I
keep a lot of friendly pressure on them
we we have to reach this goal of quality
so we all try to work together on and on
get it so here you see the development
of Amelie with this philosophy in place
so we try different haircut we have we
try to make the question really fitted
to her too so that she look like an
empress but at the same time and as I
seen Wow yeah we spent a lot of time on
the question many characters are always
hard to attack her but we are quite
excited by the result the up philosophy
now I will talk about the philosophy
with creating creating art but for games
not just art for art so first I've said
that a lot to the team art is not
graphics because to me too many people
judge the visuals of a game and focusing
only on poly poly count text to your
shadow our software's when I've studied
in the game industry people who are
talking about software as they were
hiring people based on the amount of
software they Daniel and to me it was a
wrong approach I had different people
coming with the knowledge of one or two
softwares but they were super good at
like fashion so I decided to hire them
and train them to the software I think
this is the best way you have to come
with something strong you know in them
so I repeat art is not graphics that's
why shake up the habits of the
stream no matter how powerful your
engine is no matter if you develop on
console games mobile phones whatever if
your design is weak like this one for
example it's a failure to me and your
graphics won't save anything
damn okay so let's try to see what we
gain when we work with you with the
philosophy on top of the app Department
and the benefits of a strong visual
direction I'll meetcha porn so all along
the production it motivates my team it
motivates the other team of the studio
they can project the himself you know
visually while we good super important
to give them some video
it keeps me a full of energy to have
like great topics to tackle every day it
takes ax or publisher because they see
where we go as a studio and they can
project the future campaign or they will
sell the game how they will add us so
that's also quite important we work as a
family with Bethesda and at the end of
the day the players enjoy a great and
meaningful content with badass graphics
so now you understand my willing to give
a boost to the content from the early
stage and from a project this is Kabul
in design on one to another project this
is what I call raise the bar so Emily
here and this is another one and Emily
now and these are not and I repeat it
every single day like mad guy I know
that sometimes it's easy for an artist
to take a shortcut take a photo on the
web and try to reproduce it and I'm
super perfectionist I say no trash redo
it again and we try to have our own
crafted work so I don't want you know
information from all work so this is the
evolution of Emilia in portrait mode
okay so design on one visual it was cool
you know people like the design during
the style the world and plus the
gameplay the story for sure and this is
not true that's what I said let's raise
the bar so we raise the bar in some of
graphics a lot because we've crafted our
own engine you've seen Auto boy good
designs all right so now clockwork
soldier raised the bar in terms of
movement details you see if you play the
game it's very impressive and this is
thanks to our freshly on made engine
it's based on it Tech 5 we've written
the engine not entirely but we've kept
like 30% of it so we've crafted the
engine for own needs and that super cool
to do that we got the opportunity to
move from a generation of console to a
new one so it was the perfect
opportunity to do that and while back in
time we had to call the support of
unreal or some engine we've worked on
here you have the guy inside your
Studios we just have to work and say oh
I want this shredder I want yeah well so
it's real gent wishlist of stuff and
yeah it was super cool it was tough to
do because during two years you don't
see any lighting it's all broken
the AI is all [ __ ] up if
so you have to project yourself but also
you have to motivate the team because
they can be down it super easily they
don't see the result they they launched
it crash once it was a kind of nightmare
but at some point we reached a good
stable state of the engine and we were
able to like explode the eyes of
everyone so that people value those
shifts in technology or do you think
working with the same engine for a
longer period of time would be better
for you guys as artists respect it's
well it's a discussion we have each time
we do a project and we try to have
everyone as a voice and in terms of
level design it's very important to have
a voice on the tools in terms of
gameplay story also all the tools they
use so that's not just artists that say
we want this engine
that's true that in general the engine
the first thing you see is the graphics
but then all the tools you need to
perform like animation to craft your own
AI we we script not that much we have a
lot of systems so we have to be able to
to create the system the emergent
gameplay as well so that's the
description we have all together and at
some point we say okay this engine is
better so let's let's take this one I
know that they are either had the same
conversation on prayer in Austin and
they've selected the cry engine because
it was making sense for the station
that's at all is it tough to design our
own objects like architectural clothing
when you don't have something as
important as lighting the very early
stages not knowing what to look like in
the world
yeah it's art that we are used to that
this is the way we we work we don't
create a Bible game design Bible or our
Bible will where we have lots of
materials to for eyes but we create in
an agile agile process so we've put a
lot of systems in the sandbox we let
them live and slowly we refine so it's
it was up but it's close to our
philosophy of designing games we do
every level at the same times and then
we balance then with
say what about Emily because I mean II
was not playing at the beginning so it's
like a new character and what about we
say no to the other side we'd have to
redo the level design in a way that it's
functional it's fun so we are used to
work like this you know it's ready agile
it's not like we follow a plan you know
from the beginning till the end it's
already organic okay so the bar has been
raised to level
well some people get confused whether
they look at all CG trailer this one and
from we got like torque description
about what is it in game is it not and
this is in game so they were confused
were whether they were looking at the CG
or the game suit first it was like good
feedback like okay we really raised the
bar this is just to explain that well we
did a good job on the graphics side of
the project so now the same stuff all
the previous points the this philosophy
where we were other where we get a
reference the photo trip to the Chinua
it's result in giving the game a style
and it all starts at the edge of the
known world Kanaka it's the main
character to me this is the city we have
the two main protagonists but the city's
route well it's not to explain but it's
giant beast crafted from scratch so the
story is that at the very beginning
before the law and the narration were
developed by obviousness who's the
creative director of the project we've
talked together about the carry over for
license and because it was important to
stay true to the original game as I said
some words he said corruption crime
operation disease magic decayed alright
and I said to him son is duration Magnus
Dorado front of the world these were
keywords that
that became the visual pillars of the
game
let's move at the edge of the wall and
create something fresh for the for the
players so they fill the travel into the
world it's not like this is another 1.5
it's a religion or two well so that was
the starting point and I think yeah we
have a video
it was allowing us to trade summer we
are at least a few students that
produced contact Africa so it was very
relative but it's closer to the equator
there's more vegetation as more of a
blended culture yes guys we're more
dense it's better one photo trip hidden
beach with some chairs Robinson said the
Sun dances songs the different weather
how all the people would go taking a Sun
on the beach to soar through their
melodies one of the things we also
talked about was the demographic where
the various people came from it's really
important to be the history of the city
so we studied two centuries before the
action takes place imagination there are
natives on this island and then imagine
the wave of settlers from Mali which is
a talent that will be represented in
this or not these artists too long the
upper key studied small village is been
achieved with said it bring some people
from restore from this gigantic huge
channel it was making a direct link the
world that means people from different
countries walking together are fighting
it wasn't a setup for the story of the
game so who are turns to [ __ ] mess
around the city was time to bring this
industry or around that everyone was
with I was pushing to have something
very unique so that's why we have this
giant pit much if we have wind and with
food stamp it ship we corner my first
idea was to sell Sobotka as them and one
if we put in district there were people
so imagine how they think and how they
survive in this district and brought
lots of different structures like the
windbreaker the word perhaps in the
district ourself in dementia to fill out
the window break the wind the giant
mirrors it ends up with something very
cool story-wise
visual we focused a lot more on scrapple
to are not in this one too you'll see
the contrast in the rooftops there are
fewer of the apron roofs instead you
know the Bible talks obviously has in
clarifications add so much freedom to
the original experience
now the stairs one can climb on the
backbone the fact that pays to play
solutely one thing that I like to think
about 0-2 and son of general is death
some people are labeled it as a stealth
game an action game but I think it has
some element of an exploration game it's
not only about the fighting about the
speaking it's also about like
discovering the space slowly getting
your bearings by yourself in the city
people can detect in the world you can
sneak into apartment
reviewers there are that everyone's
people really love when it's functional
and now you press pass ball you have
associate moving we design each object
so they can be built in real life I
really think that returning fans and new
players will be blown away by the
richness of new city and swirl
it's all said I can make it
forgot it was so long and CEO the
subtitle my bad english alright so back
to the city the video covered it a bit
but here we see all we focus on
inventing this city and this is a
satellite view of Kanaka we did this
mesh in 3d because to me it's really
important to understand to give the
sense of freedom of an open world in
fact or gamma it's based on mission but
it's all connected together inside the
city that you feel like it's a real city
a real open world
so yeah it's already said in the video
but we have this wind corridor that is
super cool because it triggers some
specificities to a district we have a
the red district to the north we have
industrial district to the left we have
this channel and when you play the game
for the mission to another you can see
the maybe the next mission or the
previous mission and you really feel
inside of something each time you enter
the street you feel something different
it's automatic missions in term of
narration in term of gameplay and in
term of art so this time in general -
it's it's like this remember our ladybug
in season on 1 it was special here it's
every mission that are special like this
so that's really cool and we always add
some straight tubes here some more
detail I know in the creation of this
only one you guys actually built out a
lot of the world beyond on wall as well
like you had sort of a world map develop
yeah I was there any aspects of that
that you sort of had to stick to because
they were already done for for Conacher
and honored to know we had nothing for
comic-con ok it was just a name of from
on the map and I've just succeed the
thousand points of on the globe win yeah
pointy top but that's very interesting
to have the map of the aisle because
it's different culture on its it's a
tool to create something crafted for
your game or for
this story or for DLCs alright so yeah
it's different point of view too to give
you a sense of the scale of the city
we don't do matte painting in game so
here it's in the software Maya
it's nothing game but we did this ready
Aria did this this land mass the city
and when I showed it the level designer
other not designer they were like ah
that would be interesting to go there or
there so we we did it first and then
we've painted district or interesting
around the city and we've set up the
mission that's the way we with it we
haven't done missions and then the city
so here it's a cruise of view it shows a
red district some park some hidden
harbour like you can see in you know
London by the way this was the
inspiration for that there's a small
channel they are drylock it's very
interesting because it's not flat city
it's on a hill ready organic like a
European city closer again you can find
a good piece of industrial design but
what I like with this visual is that
it's cool in term of hot all right it's
detail etc but it's compliant in terms
of gameplay in terms of circulation when
this level design and gameplay
department sees that they say ok that's
so cool that I want to reach the the top
and you're like wow so we'll have to
modify the cable so you can work we need
another solution if you have no power
because you won't be able to go there so
maybe you can process a rat and go under
the electric
tracks so you have many solution so to
me it's really a beautiful piece because
it's just not art it's it's compliant
with every department attacking studio
it's made of food you know why and now
at the street scale quickly you can feel
the playground yeah these are the first
piece we did for what is not true based
on the photo arrived on bastard and our
Cuba etcetera and you can feel we can
circulate from balcony to balcony one
already said but this is the group Paris
we have a strong sense of story no CD as
I said if we build with build the city
centuries before the action takes place
right so this was an old fort and new
Duke who's kind of as for decided to do
a pimp house you know penthouse on top
of the old fort with weird shapes or in
wood so as I said you know each mission
will be like very thematic and on
gameplay
art etcetera so that's cool
which is more video one of the big
principles that you have gained is to
say yes to the player at the beginning
of the game you're faced with the choice
between corner or Emily and then you're
faced with the choice of which pathway
to take through this crazy nonlinear
space open the window front door back
door you know like down the street over
the rooftop and on top of that Erie
faced with the play style question do
you sneak and try to avoid killing
people do you sneak and kill as many
people as possible
do you just kick the front door in and
fight your way through in terms of the
missions themselves we wanted to do
classics on missions where it's a highly
defended location it has its own
character it has its own nature you're
going after a high-value target but we
also wanted to give them some sort of
epic theming either fictionally or
gaming mechanically so that it's just
really like a completely memorable space
to move around
so for example in cracking this VAT
which is the level where you have the
ability to roll back and forth in time
you can literally move back and forth
very dynamically between two time
periods the president when the house is
in ruins for the past three years ago on
the night of a special event
when the house harsh candles are lit
music is playing guards are walking
around it's a very different feel the
challenge for us was to create two even
three different levels that would be fun
to play and where the player could go
whenever he wants in the dust district
you have these raging storms and come
about randomly you have two targets
there two factions with very different
ideas about what's better for the future
you know the level then is very special
my art is mentioned where the player can
change the configuration of each rule or
even throw levers and move the walls
floor and ceiling around you basically
reconfigure the house like a Rubik's
Cube so you can do that not only to open
up new passages but also to walk in
these behind the walls you're trying to
reach your agenda option grand inventor
for the different surahs' and you're
trying to unlock this puzzle box of this
house one layer at a time to reach him
another one of our very themed levels is
the Royal Conservatory it's like a
massive museum with taxidermy animals it
kind of gives you a view into like the
Victorian idea of natural philosophy and
science of the time just feels
atmospheric and gravity years what
happens when the players decisions meet
the story which world is what we call
emergent narrative you can enter into a
situation and we are
the world off to your impulses right now
and then you create your own story into
the only thing that I want the player to
feel about this magnitude is that our
missions our level is not they feel like
given that any one flight will dishonor
- you probably see 20% of the game it
feels to us like no two players will
have exactly the same path we've put so
much effort into having so many things
to do so many ways to do things so many
choices
I would like to play to feel like the
possibilities are endless
alright it says a lot
no legends of a park so the following
pieces despite of CG as I said centuries
before it's all done by by hand it's
pencil drawing that are that big it's
done by long gap I assume it's one of
the best war builder I know in Ventura
here always mix tank peril and creates
stunning piece drawing by hand now we
enter a building and we feel the
inspiration from the photo trip in
Barcelona he writes the inspiration is
from Ivana there's a sense of all they
manage to have to circulate inside the
building because it's very hot outside
and in general what we do is that this
drawing or so are also displayed on the
walls in the in the game because this is
the past of the city so here we can also
feel the saturation it's stunning piece
really like some more stories he writes
and all and you see the dogs in the wars
here we see a different team tiger they
don't have all the same style here you
can see a cabinet of curiosities vary
with time so from the wall but it's now
in the south so you see light rot extra
writer wouldn't throw how we manage the
other hair on the Sun inside
and if you look on words in the game you
see different stories like this we call
it the legends there are nothing to do
with the story the arc is just that I
was I thought it was fun to let the
inhabitants express themselves they
talked about this giant forest you know
so you see many paintings you know
depicting remoras legends of the war
so here it's funny because we call them
this props or generic props but they are
nothing generic we use them in different
places so that that's why it's called
generic props but you can see the amount
of details we really think our objects
or vehicle or characters to be feasible
you know in real life so that's why we
pay attention to to details like this
here you clearly see how we we try to
manage this level of details because we
were doing is not who we faced something
not expected it's the amount of details
and how to manage them you can easily
lost the player if he's overwhelmed by
objects and stuff so it was time to play
with the lighting and drag the eyes of
the guy you know it's not a movie where
it's framed and static you are internal
you enter the movie and you have to play
with the lights in a proper way to add
the experience of the player so yeah
this is not is way more dense we pay
attention to every detail and make sure
they fit the design they fit the world
here I really like it we have inventors
Karen ginger she's one of the many
inventors he crafted the world of light
the Tesla or although all the technology
that is more weapon and here are the
control part of it it's civilians we
call them the horror this is a gong in
the game and they produce their own
boards themselves so they a steel object
so here you can see the brief is in the
at the bottom right the games then I
wanted a sound trail
explosion engine so we've mixed the
flute with a light bulb like a Tesla
bulb with an insect trapped inside so
when you throw the board you know the
insect is reacting to the 2d hair it
creates light the the fruit is doing the
sound so it's cool to walk this way and
other like great ideas we'll just with
small objects so it's what happens
during the production of our games at
some point the world fit itself
you don't have to take any more
reference from our real world you just
have to go into a mission or in the
streets and you say okay I want is this
and I can create something out of this
so that's why you have lots of wood the
clockwork are made of wood because of
this giant for it with Vivid wood we
have the silver mine so you with the
only photograph in Konica it's made of
silver plates like the old tin type so
that's quite interesting and yeah that's
why I say we try to think through the
nine of the inhabitants to create them
because these are they are City there
are objects there are cloth this is the
same with the with the 9 of a
cabinetmaker who crafts the lines of
furniture we don't copy furniture on
IKEA website we do it all so that way
very particular objects blend really
well in the world so this is the
typewriter of pure love
don't forget all the weapons much
cheaper upgrade it's kind of crazy
because we can now upgrades in
difference where we have the black
market when we can get you know upgrades
we have an only archery or photo for the
forwards so it's way more advanced than
this another one and all with their
unique styles so this is from the void
so it's a twisted object and this is the
timepiece device to see to the past
Steinem love so this is about the
character I guess another side of a
patient at a cane is to bring powerful
and charismatic characters to life even
if they die quickly so please try to
play
in a little way just follow my mistake
so yeah just some references this time
we have a way more a wide range of
characters from different countries we
have mixed race so as I imagine wave of
settlers first their world is natives
then people from Mari who are the kind
of Africana you know very well then
people from Dan were more British and it
got it created some mixed race so you
can see an African all mixed with a
Mexican you know the origin so here it's
a Casas all right of great photographer
from the 90s twenties in Mexico and it's
super cool to see Mexican people like
this you know inside the city to me
Mexican it was like with a big hat you
know the cliche and I was really
surprised to see these this so it was
great inspiration for the costume they
were the weather it's fitted the way
they want to look cool you know by that
time the skin very important so then
reference done we do Anatomy studies so
he writes I stopped Kratzer hands it
gives a lot of information you see how
we manage the body language he writes a
walk here so my my wish was to that they
remove the shirt and you see the this
the mark of the Sun on the body takes
more story to me than just adding your
like badass that we come from this going
or I will say oh yeah here it's really
great you know it's Ted story and I well
okay it's the the slide about the
fashion noticed many times in different
project that some people when they
create costumes or outfits they put a
lot of gtex to make it like stand out
and to me this is a done thing this is
not the good way I prefer to think about
the guy inside the costume creates a
really nice costume for him but the
costume is the background this is the
guy quizzes very important
so it has to be fitted to him here now
we have short-sleeved to show the
discerned Gianna to me and I think to
say that I'm a descendent from a line of
taro an dressmaker my grandmother my
granddaughter so when I was a kid I
spent time you know looking at them
trying to adapt draw and adapt down
costume to a different Anatomy so this
is what I bring you know this is my own
story that's what I bring to the to the
game the way we aren't crafting because
people in the game can spend a lot of
time you know looking at objects people
etc so that's why it's really important
to me I don't want to design costume
that are loose or for everyone it's one
question per people so the result is
crews that are well Curt adjusted while
ends arms legs it's a draw and face our
new team and I have a lot of stories to
tell and it's also important to focus on
the silhouette or game you have to plan
tactics you know it's a state game it's
an assassination game so you have to
understand in the distance if this guy
is radio civilian or if he has a gun so
each silhouette or four factions adapted
to what they do and you can clearly
understand I hate doing like a lineup
where at the end you know level design
your games I know come to me and yeah we
should do this guy in red or in blue or
in green because I don't understand
I cannot plan my tactic okay so to
summarize we put a lot of effort and
patience in the preliminary research
then only we start concepting
so here is the Juke animal II we have a
strong connection with our characters
background which reflects in the anatomy
and thanks to our tech team and tools we
can develop our own shadows we can push
the limits of the graphics alongside our
unique style which is great and
should I remove this line and all of
these leads to a rich immersive expands
and when I say richer but we've we've
seen the video before it's the level of
which net that richness that allows you
to look to the past through a lens and
eventually use this timepiece device to
switch from presents and join this guy
into the past now we're going to show
you a short video of this mission
cracking the slab I think it's really
shot we can do it
doesn't it show that mention fees
billion I think we are we are good with
cronuts yeah what do we do time maybe
one audience question if anyone's good
enough to run up in Gnostic wiki yeah
run to a mic definitely loved us on a
bun looking forward to the sauna -
obviously one of the greatest things
about one of the great things about the
sauna is that you as mentioned
previously you create a world that's
much that's much larger thoughts
immediately apart to the play we have
this you know Empire of the Isles in
handy and this and that we even have
descriptions of you know what is you
know what they brow should look like and
so for them ordering it as an artist you
already kind of have an idea in your
head of what so if you need to make
games in you know TV or Molly or DC or
somewhere else do you have an idea of
what this place should look like whether
it's architecture the fashion anything
else so do you tackle these problems as
they come along no I came up because
when we started it were three years
after the first game and then we decided
to have a mini and I mean it was too
young she was 13 three years later so we
switched to 25 so 15 years later so I
cannot project myself at every you know
year of our timeline so I don't know how
she looks like we have a we have some
ideas but you have to to put a lot of
work into it will to create it so I just
have some glimpse of you guys more the
Russia so imagine like it's more cool so
how would they live and I have some ID
but you have to produce and work a lot
like you've seen in this presentation to
make it come to life but Wow yeah we
that's why we have the Empire of the
artist to allow us to to eventually go
there or do that or have people from
there that's all we have
does does that answer your question yeah
great I think I'm afraid that's all we
have time for
especially my stick around for questions
afterwards there but thank you everyone
please a round of applause for our
guests